le département organise du 31 mai au 2
juin les journées mobilité durable à
destination de ses agents au programme
de ces journées la découverte et l'essai
de divers véhicules électriques cyrille
melchior président de la collectivité a
souhaité participer à cette première
journée
passée à des déplacements
associé à
cet élan national international cordiale
de préservation de la planète de la vie
sur notre planète et sa place pourra
aussi par des nouveaux modes de
déplacement nous avons peine 5000 agents
département donc à chaque fois que
serait possible et donc d'utiliser la
voiture à la voiture en carburant d'eau
passera à de nouveaux bacs de
déplacement le vélo électrique le vélo
le la cantine est ce sont des bateaux
déplacement pour moi même ce matin j'ai
fait la démonstration que je peux comme
tout le monde aussi participer à cet
effort et je le fais déjà et donc
s'invite chaque agent a participé donc à
l'utilisation
d'un nouveau mode de déplacement doux
tels que le vélo électrique ou alors la
trottinette et un sur en se protégeant
parce qu'il ne s'agit pas de prendre de
risque on évite les accidents mais
utilisant ces nouveaux modes de
déplacement